Levon a difficult tournament for you up
to this point definitely according to
your standards uh sum it up for us up to
this point
you know
maybe I've been uh pushing too much I
think this game against
no no against the Wonder
I mean
I've played this line zillion times with
white and Blitz I queen D6 list to draw
I mean instead of rookie eight and the
other thing and I thought okay I have to
keep the game going and I bonded this
bishop D2 so that was a bit
a bit of a surprise and against Darius
yeah I should have settled for a draw in
that position and I knew that he has too
much counter play and I should just play
I saw the draw and then once again I
think I've been uh
maybe underestimating my parents and
they've been playing very well so this
is the result and today I decided okay
no more underestimate I gotta got a
place according to the position and this
is something that Wesley was mentioning
as well he always has problems with the
teenagers he was saying that he loses a
lot with the teenagers uh they're
definitely very very strong are you
surprised by their strength or not so
much no you know if if we just think
about it
this kids
especially this Asian kids you know
they're I mean to get here from Asia
your father or mother has to be a
fantastic specialist so it means they
have great gyms absolutely and it means
they're very very talented so I'm not
too surprised that they're playing very
well I'm actually a fan of all of these
players not just the Asian kids but
every every
a young guy that is playing here I think
they're very very talented let's speak
about today's game because he was
starting the game into one of these
gambits maybe he was looking to follow
up on a wonders footsteps uh were you
surprised by his opening choice at all
were you worried about it I I knew that
there is a line like this you know there
are many options for black but I knew
that Knight E4 is maybe expecting the
fried liver oh yeah always ready always
ready yes and he played D4 yeah and yeah
Knight E4 I think is a solid option
generally
no no I mean F35 sorry
what I played yes I'm here yeah I think
the main Theory goes Bishop D5 instead
of the usual D5 right yeah should be
fired yeah but uh you know why why I
mean D5 is a long long unknown Theory I
mean there is no reason to choose
something uh that is well played many
times you can also play something that
is played less absolutely and uh did it
feel like he knew what he's doing was he
moving quickly more or less you know
this bishop G5 stuff I think if you
don't play Bishop G5 then it can be
slightly worse for white I think CD
castle and then black is
yeah like gets to clean up to F6 Knight
to F4 I mean it's still around equal I
think generally but Bishop G5 is the
most solid we have some weaknesses to
play against right Bishop to G5 instead
of taking on D4 Bishop yeah and I I kind
of have to play Knight F4 I think
because castle c take the uh Knight F4
Queen E3 I think that's that you need to
know I mean I think there is also
instead of neither four there is Knight
at that moment there is Knight G5
but yeah Knight C3 or yeah this can be
slightly worse for black this end game
you have some problems on the C5 so
Knight F4 I think you need to know that
you shouldn't Castle first you should
play Knight F4 and the rest uh kind of
finds by itself the rest is history we
have to ask you about this moment that
shocked us all this game between linear
and elshon did you see what happened
yeah particular moment uh yeah I think
uh El Sean forgot to take on C4 I think
if you play this line with Bishop F5 yes
after C4 you you have to take
because if you don't think well there is
this what happened in the game do you
attribute this to him probably playing
for one of the first times the Petrov
elshon that is oh could be could be well
but I think he's a very good player but
he got affected by yesterday I think you
know the position that you see after E5
well after Knight D5 it looks like such
a pleasant position and instead he
played Bishop G4 which I actually also
blundered that there is the stage five
ID I thought oh Bishop G4 is interesting
but yeah generally I think he got
affected by yesterday's loss from
good position and maybe his nerves were
not perfect today yes an unfortunate
series of events in this one but this is
indeed competition here at the U.S
championships Levon congratulations uh
we'll see you in the rest of your dreams
thank you
congratulations
[Laughter]
but can I actually congratulate levonne
of course a bit later but he had a
birthday a few days ago and we didn't
have a chance to tell you but we said
congratulations yes so that's why yes we
have congratulations too but I was just
wondering you have accomplished so much
let's say and have you thought about
let's say your life you know when you
reach this number always those kind of
thoughts that go through your mind I
mean what what can you say about let's
say your this date and how did you
celebrate it
oh yeah well I think this is uh
more or less General tradition in uh
maybe Orthodox Christianity yes we don't
celebrate 40th birthday so I didn't
really celebrate it uh yes you know I
just had dinner
but uh Annie and her mom
um but uh
regarding to the age
you know why
I don't look at it that way like oh you
get a certain why why it should be 40 or
not 41 or or not 39. so I I think
I I know that I accomplished a lot and
then I and I always look to learn more
you know life is there to experience and
to learn things
speaking of experiencing a life Lavon
you also have a baby coming uh next
month how are the preparations going for
that moment
I'm very excited
are you tired are you having any
sleepless nights thinking about that
moment at all or not so much just
excitement just excitement more or less
yeah yeah that's great uh and Lavon just
to let you know I I'm I'm your
babysitter guy I I love kids I'm ready
to go you need a break just uh just
knock on the door if you babysit and
Bloody Mary works I babysit Jennifer ten
times worse than you commenting and I
will take you I will take you because I
love your company your baby's gonna love
me you wait you wait and see just don't
tell some of this naughty stories you
know
not a problem not a problem just uh
knock on the door that's all we ask good
luck uh in the second half uh Lavon
thank you as we prepare for a break uh
just tell us uh what